so mr ishinger you are preparing to host
one of the world's biggest conferences
on security at the end of this week how
concerned are you that we could be
witnessing a war by that time
well like everybody else
might him and i
i'm personally deeply worried
i wish
i could be confident to say that
next weekend
we will be
talking about negotiations on arms
control de-escalation mechanisms etc but
i am as deeply worried as so many
decision makers and and and analysts are
it is
um
good
that we can offer the opportunity of
munich as a as an informal platform for
discussions
but i'm afraid that if
the russian government
continues to believe that their presence
uh is not what they uh what they want
then of course our usefulness as a as an
informed platform will be somewhat
limited in recent days the us has been
intensifying its warnings and it is
explicitly saying that there could be a
full-scale war all the way to kiev do
you believe that is a plausible scenario
you always have to make a distinction
between the capabilities
and the intentions
regarding the capabilities
everybody knows not only the the
intelligence community
we've all seen the satellite
pictures
of the
number of troops
equipment our armaments etc amassed
around the
ukrainian border so the capabilities for
doing that exist
surely so that must be that must be
of course a a cause of enormous concern
now regarding the intentions
i would
be skeptical i
until proven
otherwise
i would think that
any
responsible russian military commander
and and i would also hope any russian
political
responsible leader
would think about
how
would you
once you have
moved all your military equipment
over hundreds of kilometers
into let's say up to kiev
how are you going
to keep
this huge area
with many millions of ukrainians
under your control you would have to
establish a huge number of you know
police
or permanent stationing of of of
military forces
uh in a country that is not you know
that's not liechtenstein this is a huge
country with 40 million
uh 40 million plus inhabitants so i
would think that the mere question
of you know
if you if you come to the conclusion we
could take kiev
then the question is how are we going to
hold kiev
for a month for six months for a year or
for longer and and how much will that
cost and how many lives might it cost
over the longer term
so these types of considerations would i
would hope
lead russians to
not to go down that road
now olaf schultz the german chancellor
takes center stage this week on tuesday
he's going to be in moscow he's seeking
de-escalation of the situation what can
he achieve that so far joe biden
emmanuel macron's many others have
failed to achieve
i think the best hope we can have and i
would imagine that that is
his expectation would be that he can
serve
to make
president putin continue what he's been
doing for the last couple of weeks
namely talk
in other words
having this first discussion with this
the first physical meeting between the
new german chancellor
and uh and president putin
i would hope that they would arrange
they would agree that they should meet
again
and
to continue this discussion and that
germany certainly would want to be
helpful if the russian side is willing
to
talk about diplomatic solutions to the
various issues that are uh
that are currently
uh part of this confrontation
so
being able to come back from moscow
and saying to the to the public
president putin is willing to continue
this discussion that i've just had with
him that would be as good a result as
chancellor schultz could bring home i
i'm sure that he would not
be able to come home and say i achieved
something with joe biden macron and and
and all the other leaders who've
recently met with president putin i've
i've
been able to talk him into something
that they have not achieved i think that
is not a realistic expectation now the
germans and the french are trying to
keep this so-called normandy process
going where those two countries together
with the russians and the ukrainians try
to
try to negotiate around these so-called
minsk agreements which
which came about back in 2015
there are totally different
interpretations by the russians and the
ukrainians of what these agreements even
mean
do you really see any prospect for hope
in that process
it's difficult it's very difficult i
mean it is good that there is
some
discussion
of
within the norm of the format
regrettably not at the
leader level or not even at the foreign
minister level but it's good that at
least there is some uh discussion going
on
my own
uh thinking about this
is along the following lines
we uh seem
to see that president putin
if he is willing to agree uh to
to talk
with anyone about possible solutions he
seems to prefer the united states as his
negotiating partner that's the other
nuclear superpower etc etc
so
i would be surprised quite frankly
if
in these present circumstances
the russian side
would
decide
to agree a donbass solution
in this format with france and germany
separately
my thought is this would
only come about
whatever shape and form it would have
as part of a larger package
which
president putin in my view would want to
hammer out
with the american side so my
recommendation would be
for
my own country and france
to try to
include the united states
whether in indirectly
or if possible directly
into this
normandy format you know why did the
normandy format come
into being in the in the first place
because at that time in 2014
it was not president obama's ambition to
get involved in these
um
in these european quarrels
and the thought at that time was maybe
the the germans and the french can
handle it
the way things have developed
i believe we need american leadership
now there's another level to this crisis
of course with the russians making very
fundamental demands about security for
instance demanding that nato no longer
expand the west is rejecting that
outright on the basis of real
fundamental principles this just feels
like a deadlocked situation do you see
any diplomatic way out there
diplomatic
solutions
are only possible if you go beyond
the
repetition of principles
yes indeed
i don't think that nato can go back
behind
what nato said in bucharest in 2008 that
ukraine and of course also georgia will
at some point be members of nato we
cannot say this is no longer true
this would be
tendermind to abandoning ukraine right
it would be a terrible shock to all my
ukrainian friends we can't possibly say
that
but
we can say and this is where it becomes
a little more diplomatic and a little
more concrete we can say to president
putin look
the last decision
about
eastern enlargement of nato that we took
you know in a consensus manner in nato
and nato only works on a consensus basis
was in 2004
that's almost 20 years ago
all the other nato enlargement decisions
that have taken place since were to the
south regarding montenegro croatia so
this is of no strategic interest to
russia
in the case of ukraine
even the famous decision in 2008
did not lead to any concrete steps
that would
result in
membership
of ukraine in nato
so i think there should be a way for
all of us
nato members
to reassure
the russian leadership if this is their
principal concern
to reassure the
the russian leadership
that
there is no
plan
no ambition
and nothing to fear
about
next steps
that anyone in nato would have regarding
ukrainian membership in nato quite
frankly
i cannot imagine that my own country
or france
or many other
nato members would even want to discuss
the concrete question of
inviting
ukraine into nato at this point so i
think that could be
if it's correctly done that could be
a message that hopefully would be heard
in moscow today
what's the word to to de-escalate to
start a de-escalation effort
in your report released this week ahead
of the conference you describe a major
trend that you call helplessness that is
particularly
uh affecting western democracies
helplessness the sense of
of inability to tackle major challenges
how dangerous is this phenomenon
it's uh extremely disconcerting for
for us because if
this concept which comes from you know
psychology from from medicine
if you apply that to
our international situation this is
exactly what we're trying to do
by using this concept of
learned helplessness or as we now say
unlearning helplessness
you actually condemn yourself your
society your country your group of
countries
to
regard your own role as that of a victim
others are deciding about your future
and you are quote unquote helpless you
have no
capacity
to determine which way
it's it's going to go and i you know
we've had long discussions about this uh
i am afraid that many of our citizens
not just in germany around the western
world in general and beyond uh
people believe that when they hear about
the the the climate scare the danger
that
the warming global climate will
you know start killing
humanity
people express this sense of helpless
can we do something about it well we eat
we we don't eat
stuff that comes from
from far away countries in order to
limit international traffic that is
actually
almost also an expression of
helplessness because we don't seem to be
able to to do anything about the
increasing numbers of coal-burning
plants in china or in india or another
in major other parts of the world so
we need to overcome
and this is a task not for the foreign
policy specialist this is the task for
the leaders of democratic countries to
instill in ours in in the brains the
minds of our citizens
the determination
that we have the power
to take our future into our own hands
and make sure that our children will not
live in a in a desert or our
grandchildren but in a
under under normal quote-unquote
circumstances and that we are capable of
preventing war
and that we are going to be able to
combat
pandemic phenomena
which we were
which we had not even understood
a couple of years ago now the world is
discovering is beginning to discover one
of the first was bill gates who raised
the the
the specter of uh of global pandemics
now we've learned a lesson and and i'm
quite confident that
if our governments apply themselves to
it and if the citizens understand that
this is in their own immediate and
direct interest the global community can
of course develop instruments to make
sure that the next pandemic can be
fought more effectively more quickly
with with with a
more rapid procedures to develop
vaccines if that's uh the the possible
solution than we have seen in the past
we are capable of doing a lot
and just simply this discovery of these
modern vaccines these mrna
vaccination methods
is a discovery that
even scientists could not have predicted
a decade ago so humanity is capable and
we need to relearn
our capacity to act we need to uh
to leave behind this sense of collective
helplessness that's that's our message
so it's actually goes far beyond foreign
policy it's a it's a
it's a societal issue it's almost a
philosophical issue i would like to take
one example from the current security
environment of course what happened in
afghanistan last year the debacle after
20 years of of
of war pulling out and the taliban
taking over now we see the risk of
famine taking place uh there
now there's a lot of focus on on western
military missions in the sahel region in
in northern africa
um mali for instance
the west has been heavily involved
including germany for many years now
there is no security there
what do you think are the lessons for
that situation do you think germany and
other countries should be pulling out or
would that speak of a sort of defeatism
in the line of the helplessness you talk
about
well quite frankly the situation in this
hell is of course a situation with
many aspects their military aspects
there are poverty aspects there are
terrorism aspects etc
and i don't think i don't personally
believe that
a military contingent whether it's
peacekeeping or actually war fighting is
going to do the do the trick and and and
create peace in the region
what i think
is
in terms of a larger
framework for a solution look
almost 20 years ago
the three foreign ministers of the
united kingdom
france and germany
decided
to
to
to to agree on a on a collective way to
deal with the emerging iranian nuclear
problem
15 years later
we we had the jcpoa the nuclear accord
between iran and one side and
the international community on the other
side 2015.
that accord came about because the five
permanent powers of the united nations
and other countries such as my own
country germany work together china
russia united states uk france
germany and of and actually the united
the entire european union got together
agreed on the strategy and got this
thing done
so my question is this
if we agree
if we agreed then that a nuclear
capacity by iran was going to be a
danger
to humanity and certainly to the west
why can't we agree among
all those participants that the
preservation or the recreation of
stability in the sahel region actually
in africa
in the entire entire africa continent
the prevention of
a next wave of large migratory
movements the eradication of major
sources of terrorism
and and and fundamentally islamism etc
etc requires
the same
collective approach
in other words what i'm suggesting to
you is that it's not going to be france
and germany or france and other members
of the eu this requires the cooperation
of russia
of china
of the united states and therefore i
think this is a matter for the entire
united nations community
that's what the united nations was
created for in the first place right we
haven't used this instrument
appropriately in recent years and i
would hope that the major powers
would actually empower
antonio gutierrez the secretary general
and the security council of the united
nations to take collective action this
is the perfect place
to demonstrate that the international
community can actually deal with major
challenges to international peace and
security that's what the u.n charter
says
so i think a u.n approach not a
another
you know
separate
european approach that's too little this
is a large problem it needs a large
answer
wolfgang is many thanks for your time
today thank you thank you very much